céline dion ça va très très mal céline
dion on sait qu'elle allait annuler sa
tournée américaine alors je vais dire à
les annuler sa tournée française
d'honneur et obtiendra la panne du lait
à la route et en attendant futur porte
tout le temps fait dernièrement 2020 ça
s'annule et quelques jours donc après la
fameuse vidéo instagram où justement
elle dit qu'elle reporte que ce soit les
états unis ou la france est bien
l'occasion de la fête des mères elle
n'était pas très en forme et l'a posté
ça regardez avec ses enfants et tout ça
sur instagram enfin voilà voilà voilà
ça c'est sa fille
avec des garçons et qui merde
j'ai trop fils ses trois touchés ok on a
joué encore la posture du mec qui anime
les émissions people est en train de
tomber je te légère alors partant de la
gauche
henson
nelson ces unions et rené charles né
charles la série ne va pas dans un
instant d'accord d'accord
là
on va encore dire que tu es méchant avec
ces non pas du tout et c'est non mais
c'est vrai ce que j'ai cru que c'était
comment se sortir
alors qu'est-ce qu'ils étaient donc là
la photo a été postée voilà des
nouvelles dates de tournée seront
annoncés soit dix ans en 2023 en france
septembre 2023 voilà mais malgré ce
malgré tout ça va forcément aller poster
un petit message en cette fête des mères
je me sens très privilégié de pouvoir
être avec mes enfants j'ai une pensée
toute particulière pour ces mères en
ukraine et partout dans le monde qui ont
perdu leurs enfants je pense à ces
maires qui s'inquiètent constamment pour
la sécurité de leurs enfants nous prions
pour qu'elle retrouve confort ta ta ta
ta ta ta ta ta ta et l'autre info qui
est très très importante la première est
ce que tu au courant rené charles qui le
sait ça c'est rené charles veut
reprendre le rôle de son père pour
protéger préserver sa mère dont elle
veut devenir banon rené-charles en ahl
de charles cerner et c'est le trône et
le manager on sait que de la musique un
peu de rap tout ça les ménages vont
reprendre tout ça en main parce que j'ai
bien rendu compte que tous les managers
avant ça la pâte allons marcher est-ce
que ça va se faire il y aura pas marché
non pas tellement alors moi je pense que
ça va se faire est ce que tu disais tout
à l'heure d'ailleurs été très juste par
rapport au choix qu'a fait céline depuis
la disparition de rené lui connaît la
musique qui connaît la musique jeune et
cette semaine chez nous on adagio qui
s'est exprimé dans en aparté sur canal
qu a expliqué qu'il avait tout fait pour
faire un duo avec céline qu'il avait
essayé de la condamner à multiples
reprises elle a refusé je prends cet
exemple là juste pour dire que son fils
à mon avis mais le bon personnage pour
l'amener à faire des lieux aux nouveaux
qui pourrait relancer sa carrière
j'adore badges ou mais ça m'étonnerait
fortement que pour son retour sur scène
l'énergie
ça veut dire c'est qu'on avait tourné
alors on avait tourné un documentaire
sur elle avec toute une équipe et quand
rené morts ils ont dégagé toute l'équipe
ils nous ont tout bloqué les images des
machins n'y avait plus rien et on s'est
dit n'avait plus le droit de rien dire
effectivement sur une très honnête à
part là-bas par le single de jean
jacques goldman agile et rien n'a marché
à son niveau mais a pas eu du succès et
puis après ça a été la mode et tout ça
voilà et l' autre chose elle aurait
planifié les ponts avec la famille de
rené ouais c'est le gendre de rené char
directeur de la star ac' d'ailleurs au
québec après oui s'appelle marc dupré
qui a confié qu'il n'avait plus du tout
aucune nouvelle qui n'avait plus aucune
nouvelle de céline et qui trouvait ça
très triste mais qui pensaient que le
jour où elle se sentira vraiment bien
elle remontera sur scène elle le fera
jamais à moitié pour chanter à moitié et
c'est moi je veux dire quelque chose
mais que c'est comme mon avis il ya vu
mireille mathieu et stark on se souvient
nicolas et des managers comme ça et il
ya beaucoup de couples comme ça quand ça
se termine le l'artiste ressent de
quelques chansons dans d'autres pays en
russie et tout cas puis là mais la
carrière s'arrête c'est pas le cas de
mireille pardon mais n'a pas fait de l
est pas nouveau tube mireille c'est sa
meilleure amie se met en colère c'est
pas moderne c'est vrai nom elle
s'invente pas
que sa balle sans quoi d'autres mais
tous âges accord
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
vim et vous savez que arnaud le chanteur
belge arno qui est mort l'an dernier sa
dernière volonté c'était d'enregistrer
un duo avec mireille la paloma dans plus
il a envoyé sa maquette et le jour de sa
mort mireille était en train
d'enregistrer la marque et si je fais ça
mais quand même mireille mathieu et
céline dion jeu même si j'adorais
mireille mathieu c'est quand même pas la
même chose pour moi c'est mignon c'est
une des plus grandes stars
je sais c'est que les gens s'excitent
sais pas mais tant mieux pour parler
d'état on
peut demander tout le monde connaît
defossez si c'est connu comme il me
semblait si c'est connu ça rapporte de
l'argent c'est bien c'est un peu moins
connu c'est moins bien mais c'est pas
toujours comme ça n'allait grand pagne
qui sonnait comme picasso qui sont morts
ils avaient des milieux de tableau il
était richissime et on a d'autres qui
sont morts ils n'avaient pas vendu 1 il
avait le même talent bien sûr c'est
qu'il va dire qu'elle a tellement de
tubes sous son nom ouais que je suis
convaincu qu'un jour ou l'autre parce
que c'est céline dion elle refait
fonctionnera à le ressortir un tube je
ne peux pas imaginer laisser perçoit
telle manière aujourd'hui m weezer de
cinq lacs en jeu
madonna m'a fait mal
[Applaudissements]
[ __ ] être les émissions
c'est pas possible et donc voilà donc
par intel et couper la famille de rené
elle chante plus les dates sur décalé
c'est un petit peu compliqué comme ça
vient quand même céline c'est qu'elle
est trop abîmé et actions bénéfiques
quoi incroyable
essai de bombe à écouter
et vous verrez que la suite à mon avis
quand on dit des cas les saveurs les
horguais fans mais moi en effet elle va
pas elle n'a pas dé calais décalé si ça
finira par s'annuler c'est des questions
d'assurances était trop violent de dire
aux gens arrêtent alors on décale un peu
et vous allez voir suivez moi ce que je
dis rarement des bêtises sur les icônes
me dire que ça va pas être décalés parce
que jackie lombard est nommé chevalier
si son assurance
propose ce côté là c'est compliqué ça
fait quand même